alright fellas we're gonna play a little
game a cutthroat but if you want to make
this interesting
you got to put some built stuff online
you got been autographed iJustine
autobiography status classic alright
that's cool but two gtx 1080 eyes and
that right there so you gotta step my
game up a little bit I came prepared
boys how about a statue of her boy
cosmic are you oh snap
[Music]
but someone asked me how to describe
Yakuza it sounds ridiculous but I would
describe it as like adorable but the
contrast that they use to have like this
big bad man who's just like trying to do
right he's in the opposite but he's also
kinda like made good like be a good
person while he's doing it with Jonah
I'm thought oh so they're that over
there
so no singing utility stuff Tom I hear
you was specifically and he's just one
of the many characters that make up the
series the situations that everyone
finds themselves in and the way they
just frame everything and how everyone's
characterized it's ridiculous what is
that oh my god it's one of the other
some really strong points the series
it's you're following like the same poor
set of characters through most of the
story and you get new people added in
people taken out yeah yeah it kind of
makes you more invested as the games go
on and that I think also helps
especially you're playing it like you
are right now marathoning like to hold
them straight so you're carrying
knowledge from one game into the next
with the same people knowing where they
are and what their ambitions and goals
are and I think that's something that
you'll find in a lot of other games yes
that feels incredibly satisfying because
all these games have you self continue
story that you can play on its own and
you will understand you'll get and
you'll probably enjoy it but there's
something about like playing every game
and you're like oh well that character's
doing this now and then this character
is kind of grown or fallen from grace
and you know I got in the middle of five
right now and kind of like seemed like
here use journey especially in five is
like
heartbreak game but it feels like you've
been on this like journey with this
character in the same way that like I
said television shows kind of like
capture that same feeling yeah not many
games do that like what comes close to
that you know you have entire decade
worth of story with one or multiple
characters throughout the whole thing
like oh I don't know maybe Mass Effect
yeah but Metal Gear isn't so much about
the characters whereas yahooza like that
game lives and dies by how much you care
about the characters like if you don't
care about anyone in that game you won't
enjoy the game at all but for us who are
now in the series we're like these are
our boys like we're seeing them grow and
evolve and especially for me like I
honestly think that goro majima is like
one of my favorite game characters like
of all times
[Laughter]
skin this and all day
kochira was garita Seema's there's
something about it works like we haven't
gotten tired when you think like like
six doctors again gonna row like are you
sick of it it's like no like a soap
opera like I feel like I'm binge
watching like a Netflix series and it it
feels so good
yeah and mentioning that it doesn't feel
all even through six or seven games
another thing is that you know the core
gameplay of the yahoos a series hasn't
really changed all that much I mean of
course they've improved on and they're
like with the new engine right in
welke mommy - coming and then with
yoga's a sixth avenue system that makes
tweaks - but it's essentially the same
game so you almost as someone who's like
trying to tell people about the good
word of the opposite
you kind of like have to tell that was
like awful like seven games like it kind
of plays the same like what is it
there's like no you don't understand
like it's the stories it's the
characters at the sidequest it's
everything that happens in the game that
kind of help the the idea of this like
intense crime drama and then somehow
they also managed to put in this weird
like silly Goofy's ship it just it's
such a contrast but it works so well
yeah that's that's the key to yog is
that ayah that I noticed like right away
from playing zero is that it's
incredible how they mix this melodrama
with absurdity like Yoga is an absurdist
comedy but it's also like very serious
very almost masculine type of story
where it's like big muscular men
fighting each other because who's gonna
be the boss and like who screwed me over
last time and so you'll go through like
a mission where oh I'm gonna make it to
the boss and ask him why he was trying
to frame me and then after that mission
I'm gonna go down to the the damn
bowling alley I'm gonna like play
against one of the employees and maybe
I'll get like a chicken companion to be
a financial adviser for your real estate
an actual ass chicken it is one of your
managers for your real estate company
and you put my price too and well that's
in 0-2 but like that even just that
small sub story is like speaks to just
how ridiculous this entire series is and
it just works
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and you mentioned minigames like
minigames I feel like I was such a key
part of yakuza in a way that like I
think other games kind of throw them in
more to add like more content like oh we
got this we got a card game when you
play poker and you can do that yeah cuz
it but it feels like they put so much
like thought and care and a lot of
character comes out in it where it's
like yeah you can like play pool you can
do darts but then it's like you got
karaoke and that's where like a lot of
like the characters come out where like
they're all singing like their song
[Music]
best part about the karaoke is this all
songs like they wrote for the game so
they're also like hidden like layers
like explaining like the hidden
motivations of the characters like you
sing these songs and they're like very
like dead-ass serious like a lot of
curious songs like like EG Sakura and
kiwami is about pulling yourself up by
the bootstraps and struggling to just
make a living but midway through the
song it's like him thinking back to his
days in prison
he's like pulling out like radishes out
of the ground and like swinging them
around like swords oh it works so well
too so I think that it just kind of
tough to like get people to play like a
whole big series like this you know like
and they do a lot of things where it's
like oh you can just play the newest one
you can just play sex and you're prolly
fine but I really really want to employ
people to like you know you should play
this entire series if you can like you
should start with zero
you should play kiwami you got a ps2 you
should wait back to it but it's funny
because like it actually doesn't feel as
dated that's like you think it would
like you're like oh man play a ps2 game
but then like the quality of the
cutscenes and the voice acting or like
just as high like then as they are now
and the games don't feel dated in the
way that I thought they would have been
like I feel like oh I'm gonna have to
deal with the limitations of playing
these old games to experience the story
and like a little bit of that but for
the most part like baby they still feel
like jock is our game like they've done
a really good job also like remastered
zone so we got like you want me one came
out last year now we got you want me to
so it's like you can wait and then play
kiwami too and then you just gotta you
know buy your ps3 and then play those I
really want them to put out three or
four and five actually yes she does
collection it'll be really good that'd
be really good like if you could just
play all of them like on your ps4 that
would be ideal but if you have the
ability to play all these games
you absolutely should which is what I'm
doing right now
[Music]